hi I'm anirud sarathi Global Solutions
manager with Google cloud in this video
you will learn about the different
options tools and techniques available
to modernize your legacy applications
[Music]
many Enterprise customers are struggling
to Mark nice existing Legacy
applications I've seen quite a few
companies that run in-house bare metal
on-prem Legacy applications developed 30
years ago that haven't moved to the
Cloud yet
maybe the technology they use isn't
suited for a complete overhaul or maybe
the business doesn't know where to get
started it would be nice to have a way
to quickly identify actionable next
steps on the road to modernization now
that's where tools like cast assessment
Google's fit assessment tool and fit and
Google Cloud API management apigee can
help camps application rationalization
process provides a prescriptive approach
to modernized Applications
if you're unfamiliar with Cloud
application modernization program or Cam
make sure to watch our camp overview
with you
taking the time to do this before
starting migration allows you to look at
business needs before starting to
optimize or improve applications and
processes
it is recommended to iterate this
process in waves of application this
typically depends on how your
organization is set up
the business needs identified the
assessment along with the technical
analysis will let you know which of the
r is right for you depending on the
levels of access enter the source code
you have and the number of types of
resources you have the migration route
that's best for you will change
let's talk about that more in depth
now if you have access to the source
code you can choose to refactor or
re-architect your application with the
cast assessment
cast enables you to quickly perform the
first step toward a clouded option or
migration Journey
app rationalization which is a process
for determining when application should
be retired retained re-hosted
re-platformed refactored or reimagined
cast is focused on the application layer
and provides automated source code
analysis of hundreds of application for
cloud Readiness open source risks
resiliency and Agility
objective software insights combined
with qualitative service for business
context so you can catalog and review
current application environments
unidentified opportunities for
investment rationalization Cloud
migration and Improvement these
objective software insights are combined
with qualitative service for business
context allowing business owners to more
strategic decisions about what to
refactor and when
if you only have access to a running
virtual machine you will want to use the
fit assessment tool and fit to see how
ready your workload is for a lift and
shift into the cloud or other
modernizations
our migrate to Containers tool can
migrate to Google compute engine Cloud
run GK autopilot by consuming the output
from the fit assessment tool
finally if you don't want to refactor or
rewrite your application or service you
can choose to encapsulate Legacy API
using apigee
apigee Google's Cloud API management
tool accelerates your modernization
journey by unlocking and allowing Legacy
data and applications
to be consumed by the new cloud services
as a result organizations can launch new
mobile web and voice experiences for
customers
so to recap there are three different
options for you to modernize Legacy
applications first if you have access to
the source code and are considering
refactoring it you can run the cast
assessment for helpful analysis and
insights
second if you don't have access to the
source code you can use the fit
assessment tool to assess your workloads
fit for a left and shift to the club
and third if you don't want the code at
all you can encapsulate your legacy
application instead of a Google Cloud
API management
each of these has different trade-offs
depending on your unique applications so
be sure to check out our campus
assessment tools
also remember that you have migration
options if you have funding available
through Google Cloud such as partner
Services PSO funding or PSO credits you
can use part of that funding to do the
assessment and our workload migration
or you can use the free tools that
Google has made available to run your
own assessment and then use the
information learned to migrate on your
own
or you could mix and match by using
Google's free assessment tools but
bringing in a partner to do the
migration and if you're not sure who to
partner would reach out to your Google
rep who can suggest one so there you
have it an overview of how you can get
started monetizing Legacy applications
using the cast assessment the fit
assessment tool and apigee make sure to
check out the other videos in our cam
Series where we talk about an overview
of Cam GK optimization and best
practices and tools for containerized
development
thank you for watching
[Music]